friends welcome back to bloom garden and
today we are talking once again about
the Garden today we're talking about
soil testing now you can see our garden
is all tilled up the soil is really soft
and fluffy and it's ready to plant or is
it there are a couple important steps
before we start thinking about actually
putting our plants in the soil just by
looking at the soil we can't tell what's
in here and if it will be beneficial for
the plants that we want to plant that is
why soil testing is so important just
like we need nutrients and vitamins and
carbohydrates to be strong and healthy
our plants need certain vitamins and
minerals as well that are typically
found in the soil however this Garden
has been planted several times and the
plants that were here before took out
certain nutrients and I need to know
what is existing in this soil before I
put new plants in so soil testing
measures those important minerals and
substances that are nutrients for our
plants that our plants need to grow and
Thrive and eventually produce the
produce that we're looking for in our
garden some plants do not like soil that
is high in acids most vegetables do not
so if our pH is not correct our plants
are not going to thrive so soil testing
is kind of like a little money in the
bank a little Assurance to tell us what
is going to happen to our plants once
they go in the soil part two of that is
amending the soil before the plants go
in now once we test our soil and we get
the results and we know what's in here
and what is lacking then we can add
those things that are needed that is
called amending or fixing and making the
soil proper for the plants that we want
to put in here now there are several
tests that you can do to test your soil
they can be as simple as a one test just
to test the pH you can go deeper with
nitren and poach and several others
another thing that you can do is take
some soil samples and send them into
your Cooperative Extension Office or
other agricultural lab that also has a
fee but they give you a complex rundown
of exactly what's in your soil that also
takes some
time so for me the best way to test my
soil is by using an at home test now the
one that I have selected is easy to get
from Amazon and I will link it down
below let me show you what that test is
like I am using this Luster Leaf rapid
soil test kit it measures is pH potash
phosphorus and the nitrogen
content it's a very simple test we're
just going to collect some soil and then
we're going to add some water into each
of these tubes and add a little powder
from the capsules and it will show up in
these ranges and show us where we are on
the scale from too much to not enough
help us decide what we need to add or
subtract from our soil to gather the
soil for our soil test we're going to
want to go down a few inches we're going
to want to get the soil where the roots
of our plants are going to be once
they're established that's where they're
going to be sucking up the nutrients we
really don't want to get anything on the
top of the soil because nothing really
grows on the top we also want to get our
samples from several different areas in
the garden so we have an overall view
not just one spot
[Music]
we're going to need the soil we
collected a couple of quart jars now I'm
doing three separate tests I'm going to
do the test of what the soil is made of
I'm going to test our garden soil and
I'm also going to test the compost that
I want to add into the soil later so I'm
going to do three tests but for each
test you only need one
jar you are going to need some
water measuring devices as well and I'm
just using this purified drinking water
you want to be sure that the water is
purified and not well water because
that's going to alter your testing so
purified water I have some notes Here
labels that I'm going to use and then of
course I have something to jot down my
test results of course you're going to
need your soil test kit
[Music]
now that I have my half cup in my
nutrient testing jars I'm using a
totally different jar for the soil test
it even has a smaller ring around the
top so I can tell it apart should my
label get knocked off or something I
want to be able to tell that it's
distinctly different because this is the
soil type test not the soil nutrient
[Music]
test we're adding in our 2 and 1/2 cups
of distilled water for our nutrient
testing test and now for the soil type
testing the soil was halfway up the jar
and then we add water until it's 3/4
full so the entire contents brings the
jar to 3/4 full so it's not 3/4 cups of
water it will depend on your soil if
your soil is heavy or if your soil is
light how much water you're going to add
here but you're just going to add until
the jar is 3/4
full and don't forget to add your
teaspoon of liquid dish detergent to
your soil type test jar only not the
nutrient jar just the soil test give
everything a good shake you really want
to mix it up up get everything stirred
in really really well this is going to
help us get the best results so give it
a good
shake and then you want to set it down
and not disturb it
again once you have your jars filled you
want to place them back away where
they're not going to get Disturbed again
and I realized that I also wanted to
test for the raised bed garden and I
didn't do that so I'm going to go ahead
and get that one ready and I will meet
you back in 24 hours but first we're
going to go over our little test kit and
I want to share um just what's in it and
to let you know that I will be sharing
the review after using this product this
is the first time I have used this
product so we're opening up and the
first thing I like is that is it that's
just how easy you just pull that back
card up no cutting no getting stabbed or
cut on Sharp blister packaging that you
can't open when you have arthritis that
is a huge Plus for me so I like it this
card you want to hang on to it looks
like just a piece of cardboard but
inside they have given you all kinds of
valuable information information on what
the test are how to test what's
beneficial and all those things that are
going to work into the success of using
the test and they also give you all the
information about determining what to do
after your test results so I thought
that was a load of great information
especially if you're just starting out
or you need a refresher this comes with
an eye dropper of course the capsules
you see me unpack and it comes with the
four test vials and these were a good
quality plastic and they were large
print easy to read so this was a plus
for me also by the way guys zero
sponsorship for this review this was
just one I picked up off of Amazon I
want to try it but if I'm going to try
it I want to give you the information
too so I like that the capsules are
colorcoded and you cannot mix up with
which one goes in which container the
fronts are easy to read and of course
the lid is colorcoded to the little
plastic information on the front the
range and the capsules are colorcoded to
that and you get lots of capsules so
that you can repeat the test more than
once so that is all a plus love
that as you can see everything is clear
and organized and easy to use they also
send you this little piece of paper that
has a ton of information so for flowers
plants shrubs
trees everything that you can think of
they have it categorized and the pH
level that they are most healthy at and
there's also an order form to order more
supplies so this is not a oneandone test
guys this morning everything has set
overnight and we have some interesting
findings let's look and see what of soil
we have and I'm really nervous about the
outcomes I really want to know what is
in the soil so it would be interesting
to know what I'm going to need to do to
make my soil ready for
my well here is my soil type jar and as
you can see it did separate and what
does that separation mean what kind of
soil makeup do I have what are the
things combined that makes my soil what
it is we're going to take a look
now according to the science behind this
project sand which is the heaviest of
all particles is going to fall to the
bottom the middle
layer which is very hard to see but it's
right here it's about a/4 of an inch
thick that would be the layer of silt
clay will be the top layer and if you're
lucky you'll have a lot of organic
matter up here and that's good thing
that is very good to have a lot of
organic matter the combination that
we're looking for is 40% sand 40% silt
and 20%
clay as we examine my garden makeup you
can see my layer of sand is a high
percentage my layer of silt is not and
then we have this layer of clay which is
probably more than the 20% we want it to
be so obviously my makeup is not that
perfect 40 4020 recipe
that we are looking for and I know
that's true because we live in an area
where the soil is very Sandy and sandy
soil drains very rapidly it's a blessing
and a curse water does not stand nor
does it last for any length of time and
what happens is as that clay dries out
it forms a crust and then the top of my
soil is very hard it often cracks open
and you know the recipe for making
bricks is sand and clay and to bake it
in the hot heat so that's what I get and
I know we can make this better I have
some organic material we can add more
organic material into this by taking the
things that I've added to the raised bed
and that compost and adding it into my
big garden soil I believe that we can
certainly make this work and get closer
to that perfect 40 4020 recipe
so here we have our three jars and this
is our raised bed soil this is our
regular garden soil and this is the
compost that I had delivered that I
would like to add to this now I think
adding this to this because we just
looked at that Garden makeup is really
going to help that middle layer that I'm
lacking in now these I didn't separate
because I didn't do that kind of a test
I didn't add the soap and I didn't shake
them um other than just to mix them
so we don't know the makeup of how much
sand and L and and everything well we do
this one because we that's the one we
actually measured but for the raised bed
and the compost I really didn't feel
that that was important the raised bed
is all added soil so I had bag soils
that I've purchased and then last year I
added a lot of this and this year I
filled my beds with this and I mixed it
really well well so that's why these two
look alike because there is a lot of
this in this and you can see though that
there are other things in here because
while this is real watery at the top
this does have more heavy materials in
it
so let's get into the nutrition content
and see what we
have now I'm going to start with the
large garden soil first and we're going
to do the pH test first the pH test is
done a little different L we're just
going to put soil in the container just
to that little line and I don't know if
you can see them then there's another
little fill line with water and we're
going to put in the tablet and it will
tell us on the scale where our pH is for
the large garden
soil now there is a sweet spot it is
right in here and that is where our
vegetables like to be so so hopefully
our pH is at that
level let's take a minute to talk about
pH and why we test it what is pH pH is a
measurement of the acidity or the
alkalinity of something in this case
we're talking about our
soil it is measured on a scale of 0 to
14 and seven is neutral as the numbers
go down from Seven it is more acid and
if it goes up it is more alkaline and
like I said there is that sweet spot
about
65.5 6.5 somewhere in there now there
are acid loving plants and fruits and
there are some who like it more alkaline
but for our purposes we want it kind of
right there in the middle soil PH
also influences soil dwelling
microorganisms and organisms like
earthworms that provide benefits for our
plants and help our plants take up other
nutrition
and you can see here that just in the
few seconds that we're testing we're
kind of right in that slight acid 6.5
perfect spot now we're going to move on
and do our garden soil nutrient testing
and we're going to test for the
important nutrients found in the soil or
should be found in the soil and we're
just going to use the water that we've
already mixed up yesterday and allowed
to sit overnight and we're actually
going to test all three soils but right
now we're going to start with the large
guard soil and we're going to do our
nitrogen our pot as and our phosphorus
and I'm just going to talk about why we
do the test you can see how I'm doing
the test so if you have questions go
ahead and put them in the comment
section but we're just going to get in
and talk about the importance of these
tests now nitrogen is needed in the
greatest amounts it's what feeds our
plants it is the first number on on all
fertilizers both organic and
synthetic not only is it the most needed
it's the most readily lost from the soil
as our plants are planted they're taking
up those vitamins and nutrients and
they're using it up so it gets used up
easily
and it's vital it's a the natural part
in chlorophyll manufacturer through
photosynthesis it stimulates leafy green
growth and promotes that healthy plant
and encourages seed and fruit
development or produce as you know
tomatoes and peppers and all those
things so you can tell when you're
deficient because you have overall Leaf
yellowing and very weak plants and if
your plants are weak it limits the
ability for them to take up phosphorus
which is another poor important part
moving on to pot ash or potassium they
call it potass or pot ash because back
in the day they extracted it by putting
ashes in a pot and squeezing them down
and getting the nutrients
out potassium or pot ash is one of those
essential nutrients for all plant and
animal life it synthesizes plant sugars
and it helps it uptake food it protects
the plants against stream temperatures
fights stress fights diseases protects
against wilting strengthens those roots
and the stems it helps them use water
efficiently so without it magnesium
stagnant or would cease to grow and it
would be a crucial balance in the
alkaline soils so very important that we
keep up with our
potassium phosphorus is another
important element it's also included
it's that second number in all
fertilizers and it helps plants uptake
those other nutrients building strong
roots and it's easy to see your
deficiencies because your plants are
small they may not produce any flowers
and because most things are grown for
their blossoms their blooms their
flowers their produce it's very
important to replace that
phosphorus okay our time is up and our
tests have settled it is now time to
determine the makeup in our plants and
we have the color along the left side is
going to match with the ones along the
right and wherever that color is that
looks the most like the one on the other
side that is it so it looks like our
acid is just about perfect and our pot
ash is in the sufficient range it looks
like we have plenty of phosphorus in
this Garden so it looks like we have a
lot of good nutrition going on now it's
really important to document your
findings because you think you might
remember but you won't
and I'm doing three different tests here
so I want to be sure to document them so
I can come back later and know exactly
what I need to do I really like how well
this kit cleans up because we're going
to do another test we're going to go
ahead and wash everything and get it
ready for the next test these little
plastic ID cards that are on the front
come right out their plastic so they're
not going to get ruined when you wash it
when you're ready to dry it just to make
sure sure that it is really dry on the
inside you don't want any other residue
go ahead and use a Q-tip now we're going
to move on and we're going to test the
soil from the compost and just see what
kind of nutrients are in the compost
that I've already added to the raised
beds and that I want to add to the big
Garden we're going to go ahead and start
with our pH and again with the pH test
you add a little bit of soil in the
bottom you're distilled water and you
give it a good Shake uh of course you
add your little green tablet in there
and that's going to tell you your
overall composure if you have a swimming
pool you probably do these very similar
tests to test your pH and other things
that are in your swimming pool so you
may be used to these kind of tests or
you may use them for something else next
we're going to test
our acidity in the soil and again we
want that sweet spot right around
6.5 and we're going to do the pot ash as
well and you can increase the pot ash in
your soil by adding
wood Ashes to your fire now you want
good wood ashes here you don't want to
use treated lumber or anything that
you've burnt like that but if you have a
fire pit at home and you burn and have
fires or you have a fireplace or a woodb
burning stove empty in your ashes in
your garden is a great way to improve
that overall potash and then tillin in
the
spring so next we're testing our
phosphorus we're going to give that a
quick shake and we're going to wait our
10 minutes and see what our results
are well it looks like we have a lot of
alkaline in the soil but it's not too
acid so I think it's going to be okay
there is plenty of nitrogen now remember
this is a compost so it's it's going to
be higher in nitrogen and good
fertilizer so that is a plus now the pot
ash here looks like we're kind of a
little below adequate and the phosphorus
is the same it's kind of between
adequate and uh sufficient so this is
the makeup of the compost and adding
that to the test results that we've
already gotten in the big Garden I think
I can safely add this without having to
make any adjustments to any anything I
think we're totally fine to add these
and it won't affect our outcome uh
adding a little more nitrogen will be
fine and
um yeah I think it's going to be great
to add to the big garden now another
wash and now we're going to test the
raised bed now I'm really excited to get
the results of the raised bed because
like I said I've controlled the soil I
have added really expensive organic
soils and composts to this bed so I know
that it's had a lot of good things go
into it but because they are a small
area my raised beds are 3T by 5T and I
plant them every year again the
soil
is taken up with those things that we
use the most and and so our plants have
already used up a lot of those things
but I add in every year so I think I
should be really good
as so like I said I know things get used
up I've put a lot in and I have control
of this way more than the great big
Garden so I'm anxious to see where we
are and if I should feed this year or
what I should do to make sure that I'm
getting great cops and I usually do my
kitchen Garden where the raised beds are
usually provides great produce healthy
plants uh it's a beautiful garden when
it's in full bloom so I think we should
be just
fine I will have for you in the
description box ways that you can amend
your soil if your pH is too high or too
low if you need more poach if you need
more nitrogen I will give some good
ideas down in the description box below
now I'm ready and look my soil is
completely alkaline my veggies are not
going to like that at all I'm really
glad I have it planted yet nitrogen
really low here isn't it wow I'm really
surpris I have to say I'm really
surprised I thought that this would be
really good
my pot ash is not too bad and my
phosphorus could use a little bit
more I'm very surprised I have to say
this garden needs some work now that I'm
done I'm getting everything a really
good wash this stores back in this
package really easily guys I'm going to
give this a festar review I so happy to
have this test I loved everything about
it thanks so much for coming along today
and learning all about testing soil and
learning the makeup and the nutrient
value in your soil I sure learned a lot
today some things I wasn't surprised but
a couple things I was really surprised
so I learned the fix for the big garden
and this particular make make up is to
add that compost mixture in before I
plant it's going to really help this
Middle Line the silt and really help
keep moisture in my garden and not drain
fast because it's Sandy and also it's
not going to change any of the nutrients
but even though I used that same compost
in my raised beds and added a good
organic soil in there I was really
shocked to see how depleted most of the
nutrients were in those raised beds so
now I have my work cut out for me I'm
going to up that nitrogen content of the
raised beds and do a couple other little
twists before I plant them and I'm so
glad I learned this because I'm planting
I'm planting in just a couple of days
here so I'm really glad I learned this
information I hope it inspired you to
take that extra step and learn a little
bit more about what is in your soil so
that your garden will be a success your
plants will grow strong healthy roots
and produce an abundance of fruit so
thank you so much for stopping by the
farmouse today guys and until next time
be blessed and be safe and I'll see you
soon